bueno para la cancillería peruana las
declaraciones del presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador resultan
graves y constituyen una inaceptable
injerencia en asuntos internos de ese
país el Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores de Perú también señala que
esto representa una violación al
principio de lo que se denomina en
términos diplomáticos la no intervención
es un principio que tiene que guardar
todos los estados y por eso el embajador
mexicano fue declarado persona no grata
justamente el gobierno Azteca ha dado
instrucciones al embajador Pablo Monroy
para que retorne inmediatamente ese país
porque señalan que debe guardar su
seguridad y su integridad y también esta
tarde el gobierno peruano le otorgó el
salvoconducto a la primera dama Lilia
paredes para que ella y sus hijos puedan
seguir el asilo diplomático que les ha
otorgado México se espera que en horas
un avión mexicano recoja a Lilia paredes
y la lleve con destino a tierras
mexicanas